[Music]
cybersecurity researchers are raising
concerns about Amazon's new service you
know the one that lets drivers deliver
packages inside your home Amazon key is
a way for drivers to unlock and relock
your door and record their entry with a
wireless security camera but that
convenience may come with a very serious
risk and rewards here with what experts
say is a glaring security vulnerability
in the new system and a good morning
well good morning the new Amazon key
system lets the company's drivers open
your front door with the security of a
camera watching them but the findings of
one security research firm raised
questions about whether that camera will
be capturing what's really going on if
it is digital it is hackable that's what
cyber security expert John salió told us
in October about the new in your home
delivery service Amazon key I want to
see the hackers get a chance at it and
see what they do with it
three weeks later they've had their
chance and say they've already found
flaws here's how Amazon says it's
supposed to work for $249 the company
sells you a special smart door lock
along with an in-home wireless camera
aimed at the door a delivery driver uses
an app to alert Amazon they have arrived
the company then activates the camera
and unlocks the door remotely the driver
drops off the package steps outside and
tells Amazon to lock the door but now
researchers from Rhino security labs say
they've found a weakness in the security
camera system the potential for hackers
to use what's called a D authentication
attack if they did an attacker will be
able to walk in they will be able to
leave and you won't be able to see
anything and there won't be a record in
this Rhino security demonstration a mock
driver finishes dropping off a package
then here on nearby hacker sends
commands to the Wi-Fi server the
security system relies on and
temporarily takes the camera offline
before the door locks again this is a
really simple thing to do it just takes
one command in their model while a
customer's app still shows a closed door
a would-be burglar could walk inside
without the
camera seeing him rhinos CEO Benjamin
coddled by being able to disable this
camera we're we're essentially reducing
that security or to essentially just
providing a physical key to your home
amazon says that flaw isn't an its
software that it's a vulnerability all
Wi-Fi servers contain the company plans
to put out a software update later this
week to more quickly provide
notifications if the camera goes offline
during delivery and make sure the
service will not unlock the door if the
Wi-Fi is disabled and the camera is not
online Amazon also calls these types of
attacks unlikely but Caudell disagrees
based on the simplicity of the attack
$20 and some really available software
you can implement this yourself
well amazon told us they do not believe
customers would be put at risk by this
in their view it is not a security issue
they say they thoroughly background
there Jill literally delivery drivers I
should say but call data Carlton
he and his researchers were kind of
surprised to find this sort of
vulnerability in a program that lets the
drivers into your home so it doesn't
sound like Amazon thinks they need to go
back to the drawing board on this one
amazon says they're going to make this
software update but coddle says there's
sort of a larger question there about
security architecture design the awesome
that he's a little surprised by I like
your dog said if it's digital its
hackable I like Amazon fresh and I'm
wondering if they can not only bring it
in but they can put the meat in the
Frank you so much